le cdas de 7,80 et le département de la
réunion vous présente le 23e championnat
régional d'orthographe
le titre il ya bien longtemps
il y à bien longtemps à la ligne
ce matin là ce matin la virgule
tout était calme
tout était calme virgules
esi bleu paisible
ouais le soleil resplendit 7 2009 le
soleil resplendit c'est de mille feux
points so le jeu d'ombré et de lumière
sous le jeu d'ombré et de lumière
virgule
le cirque de cilaos le cirque de cilaos
entouré de ses remparts
le cirque de cilaos entouré de ses
remparts dominé par ses remparts dominé
par les sommets les plus prestigieux les
sommets les plus prestigieux de lille
virgule comme cette phrase est très
longue et que cette partie concerne plus
particulièrement les cm1 je vais
l'accueillir depuis le début elle n'est
pas finie rassurez-vous est très
attention regardez bien votre copie sous
le jeu d'ombré de lumière virgules le
cirque de cilaos
entouré de ses remparts dominé par les
sommets les plus prestigieux de l'île
virgule apparaissait comme un écrin
comme un écrin de verdure tapissé de
fleurs
fleurs points fin de la dictée pour les
cm1 à la ligne un splendide soleil
inondait splendide soleil inondait de
ses rayons
un splendide soleil inondait de ses
rayons argenté et brûlant
ces rayons argenté et brûlant le petit
village
le petit village blotti là blottie là
comme un nid d'oiseau comme un nid
d'oiseau points
les cases construites en bois les cases
construites en boire aux toits de paille
aux toits de paille bien gül n'était
accessible que les cases construites en
bois autour de paille virgule n'était
accessible que par des trois sentiers
rocailleux par des trois sentiers
rocailleux serpentant
serpentant à travers les replace à
travers les rues places et les profond
ravin à travers les rues plat et il est
profond ravin poindre fin de la dictée
pour les cm2 à la ligne elle était
entourée de petits jardins
elle était entourée de petits jardins ou
de petits jardins où se mariait les
odeur capiteuse se mariait les odeur
capiteuse des fleurs et des blancs 2
aromatiques les odeur capiteuse des
fleurs et des plantes aromatiques
point les constructions les plus
importantes les constructions les plus
importantes sa ligne en s'alignant de
part et d'autre de part et d'autre d'un
tronçon de route en terre battue de part
et d'autre d'un tronçon de route en
terre battue je viens gül constituait le
village constitue l le village plus
pompeusement plus pompeusement surnommé
surnommé ouvrez les guillemets la ville
la ville fermez les guillemets point
fait de la dictée non je me suis avancé
c'est pas encore la fin à la ligne pour
tous poteau le
les 6e 5e 4e et 3e on continue avec les
sixièmes celle là c'est là qu'on
trouvait les boutiques
c'est là qu'on trouvait les boutiques
virgule l'école et la mairie annexe
l'école et la mairie annexe points fin
de la dictée pour les sixièmes à la
ligne à l'orée du bois à l'orée du bois
virgules la petite église surplombait
tout le paysage la petite église
surplombait tout le paysage
malgré les difficultés d'accès
malgré les difficultés d'accès virgule
cilaos
si la housse
virgule grâce à ses eaux thermales
grâce à ses eaux thermales virgule à la
pureté de son air à la pureté de son air
virgule aux aspects resplendissant de
ces montagnes aux aspects resplendissant
de ces montagnes virgule aux remparts
changeant de couleur au rempart
changeant de couleur au gré des heures
et des saisons au gré des heures et des
saisons virgule était un pôle
d'attraction pour les gens de la côte
est est un pôle d'attraction pour les
gens de la côte points
fin de la dictée pour les cinquièmes à
la ligne l'impression de calme
l'impression de calme virgule de
sécurité coffret le cirque l'impression
de calme virgule de sécurité coffret le
cirque était renforcée par le chant des
cascades été renforcée par le chant des
cascades dévalant les pentes les
cascades dévalant les bandes virgule
comme des chevaux aux crinières mouillé
des crimes comme des chevaux aux
crinières mouillé des kumm sur des
roches saillantes sur des roches
saillantes points
le doux murmure des ruisseaux combler le
creux des ravins le doux murmure des
ruisseaux peuplaient le creux des ravins
et les sous-bois et les sous-bois de
leurs mille voix de leurs mille voix
points dans le cirque
bienvenue dans le cirque virgules la vie
n'était pas facile la vie n'était pas
facile virieu mais les gens vivaient
heureux mais les gens vivaient heureux
points fin de la dictée pour les
quatrièmes à la ligne
dans ce havre de paix et de fraîcheur
virgules ils s'entraident
il s'entraîne des poèmes
il n'était relié au monde extérieur
il n'était reliée au monde extérieur
virgules
par delà les montagnes hommes par delà
les montagnes virgule que par des trois
sentiers accidentés que par des trois
sentiers accidentés virgule rocailleux
rocailleux bien lieu tél les sentiers de
mafate
tél
les sentiers de mafate points
à la ligne on y vivait de la culture de
maïs on y vit vert de la culture de maïs
virgule de lentilles de lentilles
virgule de haricots de haricots virgule
de légumes et d'élevage de légumes c'est
de l'élevage points lorsqu on descendait
à la ville
lorsqu on descendait à la ville virgules
c'est un pour s'acheter du tissu 70 pour
s'acheter du tissu virgule des
allumettes les allumettes via gueule du
pétrole du pétrole bienvenue du savon du
savon via gül
tout ce dont on ne pouvait pas se
procurer tout ce dont on ne pouvait pas
se procurer chez le commerçant du
village chez le commerçant du village
point final
je relis le texte de la dictée
il y à bien longtemps
ce matin là tout était calme paisible le
soleil resplendissait de mille feux sous
le jeu d'ombré de lumière
le cirque de cilaos entouré de ses
remparts dominé par les sommets les plus
prestigieux de l'île apparaissait comme
un écrin de verdure tapissé de fleurs un
splendide soleil inondait de ses rayons
argenté et brûlant le petit village
blotti là comme nid d'oiseau les cases
construites en bois aux toits de paille
n'était accessible que par des trois
sentiers rocailleux serpentant à travers
les replace et les brochon raffin elle
était entourée de petits jardins où se
mariait les odeur capiteuse des fleurs
et des plantes aromatiques les
constructions les plus importantes
s'alignant de part et d'autre d'un
tronçon de route en terre battue
constituait le village plus pompeusement
surnommée la ville
c'est là qu'on trouvait les boutiques
l'école et la mairie annexe à l'orée du
bois
la petite église surplombait tout le
paysage
malgré les difficultés d'accès c'est la
hausse grâce à ses eaux thermales à la
pureté de son air aux aspects
resplendissant de ces montagnes aux
remparts changeant de couleur au gré des
heures et des saisons et tu es un pôle
d'attraction pour les jambes de la côte
l'impression de calme de sécurité
coffret le cirque était renforcée par le
chant des cascades dévalant les pentes
comme des chevaux à crinière mouiller et
légumes sur des roches saillantes le
doom et au mur des ruisseaux peu plein
creux des ravins
les sous-bois de leurs mille fois dans
le circle la vie n'était pas facile mais
les gens vivaient heureux dans ce havre
de paix et de fraîcheur
il s'entraînait il n'était relié au
monde extérieur par delà les montagnes
que par des trois sentiers accidentés
rocailleux tél les sentiers de mafate
on y vivait de la culture de maïs de
lentilles haricots de légumes et de
levage lorsqu on descendait à la ville
s'est elle pour s'acheter du tissu des
allumettes du pétrole du savon tout ce
dont on ne pouvait pas se procurer chez
le commerçant du village le nom de
l'auteur anne marie rivière
l'action pour que les enfants puissent
faire des progrès en autographes sur
toute l'île sur les écoles de toute
l'île et les collègues de toute l'île et
est aussi sûr pour les enfants des îles
boris banga ce cas comment et seychelles
donc c'est pour que les enfants puissent
perd régulièrement des dictées syndiqués
aujourd'hui eh bien non nous
privilégions sans dire que nous ne
prenons pas des auteurs autres que ceux
de la réunion mais nous essayons de
privilégier les hauteurs de la réunion
et ce livre écrit par madame anne marie
rivière sur son histoire de son père
comme je disais son père qui était
amputé des deux jambes par une fois ce
qu'elle avait fait la guerre et elle a
écrit l'histoire de son père où je
trouvais que ça ça pouvait être un bon
texte
cossette avait déjà impressionné pour
nous aider dans le cantal on s'est
concerté avec les cdas organiseront deux
raisons parce qu'on croise on veut faire
vous montrez que vous êtes
demain zaki talents cachés qui vaut 8
500 m
le 23ème champion régional haut de gamme
bien sûr tous à l'eau les performances
des élèves
les collégiens non seulement de la
réunion mais aussi des îles 200 hier
évoquant le maurice les seychelles et le
mal de retard et je vous demande à vous
dit en souriant
il est vrai plaisir à souligner que ce
championnat avant sa contribution à la
halle à vis de la langue française dans
cette zone de l'océan matière nous
remercions tous très sincèrement tous
ceux qui nous apportent aide et soutient
les parents bien sûr vous êtes à vendre
eux ce soir les parents qui soutiennent
leurs enfants les enseignants et puis
tous ceux qui nous aident financièrement
le losc leur dira ce soir orange réunion
qui est reprise y est là aussi et on l'a
fait fm radio rachat veut pour tout près
et vous pourrez entendre et voir aux
enfants sur crayon fnpl maps et australe
permet d'accompagner les enfants
les champions lors du séjour culturel
vu en octobre à paris la députée de
gatineau qui nous a aussi aidés et
l'ancien la radio ni de la réunion bien
sûr parce que doux tout ce que nous
faisons passe par la famille de l'amour
c'est à saint denis de la réunion qui
distribue les règlements dans les
établissements scolaires est évidemment
le concept département nous accompagne
depuis maintenant plus de trente ans et
c'est le procès des trente membres à
lutter et à l'aune de la naissance du
cdas à tous
je tiens à vous dire et redire l'énergie
merci aussi à tous les bénévoles du
sénat sans ces personnes là où ne
pourront pas faire ce que nous venons
dans les écoles car vous ne voyez là que
le championnat remarquable de danse
d'arts légal
mais nous intervenons aussi en plastique
en asie les bijoux genre j'en oublie
nous sommes dans les crèches parce que
nous commençons nos actions pas
seulement pour les élèves qui sont en
place mais aussi des des petits enfants
qui sont dans les prêches tarde donc
merci à tous et bon retour chez